there is something loose on this planet
is that what I want to say or behind
reality or something I we could call it
the unconscious but that might make you
feel more comfortable with it than you
should but what this power can do is it
can manipulate your mind and what it has
access to is the complete contents of
your experience it has more access than
you do you the ego are a fragile and
forgetful creature this thing every
movie you've ever seen every television
show you've ever watched every headline
you've ever glanced at ever every face
you've ever noticed in a cog it has it
all and when it sits across the board
from you and the pieces are displayed it
it absolutely surrounds and encloses
your mental universe and can manipulate
you any way it wants to because it knows
you far better than you know yourself as
an example of this because it's very
hard to catch this thing in action it's
it's mercury sly but not it's not
perfect it's not God like it's just
99.8% able to do this trick without ever
being nailed to the wall for it here's
an example of the 0.02% where it failed
and you if this seems to make no sense
to you you should read my book true
hallucinations in which the story I'm
about to tell is embedded but my brother
to shorthand it catastrophic Lee went
pretty bananas in the course of this
expedition to the Amazon and at one
point he announced that he was going to
deliver a teaching that would I think
this was the one which cured all disease
you you only had to do this practice and
all physical disease would instantly be
cured and he said and so here's the
practice he said pictured the number-8
turn it on its side slide the two
circles together shrink it to a point
close your eyes
yep and utter the mantra please okay
sounds like it as a 30 40 chance of it
at least knocking back hayfever right so
so this was at a point in this
experience in the Amazon where he had
been raving for days and days and just
everybody was exhausted and at the wits
and and but it was like a bolt of
lightning to me because I remembered
that three months before I had been in
Canada having come from Japan and was
getting ready for this Amazon expedition
and one of the things that I thought I
should take care of since I'd been in
Asia for a couple of years was I needed
a dental checkup so I made an
appointment with this Canadian doc
dentist and went for this dental
cleaning and arrived to find a waiting
room full of people and settled down to
a tall stack of tattered and incredibly
tacky magazines among which was the
Journal of the Canadian
education society something like the
parent-teacher magazine but for Canada
and there was an article in there said
this was 1971 shows you how things never
change there was an article about how
computers will soon revolutionize
elementary school teaching and so you
know in desperation I turn to this
article and here's this article you can
imagine what it was saying but there was
this little sidebar next to the article
and it said the schools of the future
will be nothing like we have known
children will learn in completely
different ways and then it said imagine
little Susie sitting down in front of a
computer screen visualizing the number-8
turning it on its Sun sliding the two
circles over each other and shrinking it
to a point in order to command an
arithmetic operation or something like
that and it was like nailed nailed we
know where this stuff is coming from
it's coming from our own minds
you know hee hee if we want to blame my
brother for this had apparently a
complete readout of all this detritus
flowing around in my mind and could pick
it up and use it at will to befuddle and
confuse me and lead me deeper in